Great Britain now this is how you
high-five a beef where Richard Brown is
abuzz about his new best friends hey B
high-five about to see more I'd like to
see somebody fist bumping to us hey be
fine totally fake
I give this video a beep so I written to
be really BFFs be high five although
this clip may seem unbelievable it's a
hundred percent real this might look
like good friends but this B is not
being friendly quite the opposite he's
actually activating a defense mechanism
in the be something called posturing
basically the B's way of saying you
daddy if rich keeps getting closer it
might put up a second leg and even
closer than that it could roll on its
back and present its stinger this is
nature's clear way of saying hey I have
this sharp thing come closer and it will
be in you
generally speaking bumblebees are not
aggressive insects and in fact they play
an extremely important role in
pollinating many of the fruits that we
like to eat so don't annoy them because
you might get hurt and hungry